there are nearly 900 species of Pokemon
out there and while the Pokedex is full
of super cute descriptions about
bringing happiness and playing at the
beach there are plenty of really
disturbing stories in there - some
Pokemon are poisonous
some are aggressive and others Street up
eat each other Ekans and Sneasel both
feast on Pidgey eggs for example but
that's just normal food chain stuff and
when compared to some of the other
pokemon out there it's child's play
cubone wears its own mother's skull and
according to red version
Charizard can cause forest fires
unintentionally I'm sure Smokey the Bear
appreciates that the darker pokemon are
messed up in different ways so let's
break this down into a few categories
how about a little appetizer to ease us
into the heavier stuff the ones that are
food for years science has wondered
whether or not we can eat pokemon and
what they taste like the good news is we
can and according to Pokemon Diamond
chair ruby is very sweet and tasty sword
and shield additions al creamy and
Appleton are delicious too they secrete
sweet cream and nectar respectively
which little kids enjoy snacking on if
you're looking for a main course Pokemon
offers some fish and fowl Barracuda is
another new sword and shield edition
with surprisingly tasty flesh and that's
definitely the last time I want to use
the word flesh to describe my food crab
brawlers claws are prone to falling off
and moon version tells us the meat
inside them is rich and delicious then
there's Farfetch'd according to the
anime series it's a delicious duck
especially when cooked with a leek now I
know what you're thinking doesn't
far-fetched carry around a leek already
yeah it carries around its own garnish
that's like a chicken carrying around
cajun spices and buns and hanging out
inside a Popeye's at least you can wash
the guilt out of your mouth with a sip
of tea from poltergeist because yeah it
lets its trainer drink it sometimes I
hope you're cool with drinking a ghost
oh did I not mention that poltergeists
used to be a person the ones that are
people yeah it's time to get dark
poltergeists previous form sin estilo
nee spirit possessed
a cold leftover cup of tea I guess ghost
types do have to be the ghost of
something but it's really creepy when
that something is people oh and
spiritomb it's made up of a hundred and
eight different spirits that thing you
keep in your pokeball is a hundred and
eight individuals who lived full rich
lives now they hang out in a Pokemon PC
when you don't want them in the party
anymore meanwhile yah mask carries a
mask that used to be its face when it
was human this floating thing very
explicitly used to be a person even
worse its evolution cough egregious
swallows those who get too close and
turns them into mummies so there could
easily be some sort of messed up
self-fulfilling prophecy here where
cough egregious keeps churning out dead
bodies that become yaw masks and carry
around their old human faces that's a
vicious cycle hopefully at least some of
these are adults who've already lived
most of their lives because in phantoms
case Pokemon Y specifically says it's a
tree stump possessed by the spirits of
children who died while lost in the
forest
dead kids and Pokemon very wholesome
even Kadabra used to be a kid firered
says avoid with extrasensory powers
awoke in bed transformed into Cadabra
I'm not sure what's worse waking up in
some coffe gassed body horror or just
dying in the forest oh by the way
Pokemon themselves die too the ones that
die remember that harrowing episode of
Pokemon where Charmander stale fire
almost went out yeah fire red says it
dies if that happens another anime
favorite is Jigglypuff who of course
loves to sing and put people to sleep
but according to Sapphire it never
pauses to breathe if it is in a battle
against an opponent that does not easily
fall asleep Jigglypuff cannot breathe
endangering its life worst karaoke guest
ever spike is a pretty cute pokémon too
but apparently that little spring it
bounces around on is what makes its
heartbeat Omega Ruby says that yes that
means if it stops its heart will stop
meanwhile clan can't afford to mess up
in battle it's composed of two gears but
if the mini
it launches that a foe doesn't return it
will die try not to miss buddy if all
this has you upset just be glad you're
not primate son version says it has been
known to become so angry that it dies as
a result so that's fun but what about
those Pokemon that want to hurt us the
ones that murder have you ever been
stung by a jellyfish
well Jellison takes things a bit further
than that ultramoon says fishermen are
afraid of it because it drags them into
the sea where a whole heap of sunken
ships are sitting in its lair I'm not
sure if I'd rather drown or have my back
broken but beware it can take care of
that
let me just read what moon version says
about what is essentially just a giant
teddy bear many trainers have left this
world after their spines were squashed
by its hug beware isn't the only
accidental murderer in the Pokemon world
either anyone who sees what's under
mimic use disguise dies from the sight
also it has a broken neck that it can't
fix so it just cries all the time poor
thing
I have zero sympathy for sandy gasps
though because it takes control of
anyone who puts a hand in its mouth
even worse its evolution palos and keeps
the bones of all of its victims buried
underneath it the beach is supposed to
be a happy place and I can't go up to
the mountains either because I don't
want to run into Frost lass that thing
freezes people and turns them into
decorations in its den Ed Gein style at
that point just take my soul - speaking
of which the ones that steal your soul
yes even in death you're not safe from
these evil pokemon dusclops has a hollow
body that will steal your spirit if you
happen to see what's inside shedinja and
Sableye straight-up steal souls - and
you know that ghastly trio of liqui
clamp int and Chandelure well every
single one of their flames is the soul
of someone who passed on lit wick even
leads people into the forests in some
sort of sick team-up with phantom black
and white to say lamp it waits outside
hospitals waiting for people to die god
forbid it's another kid because drifloon
and it's evolution drifblim both carry
away small children to the afterlife
if Pennywise carried around these guys
instead of that red balloon we would be
so screwed now you might have noticed a
lot of these messed up Pokemon are ghost
types and a lot are from gen 1:1 trio of
Pokemon fit both of those descriptions
and I've saved the worst for last the
unholy trinity
gastly Haunter and Gengar dare I say
these three are the originators of the
pocket monster McCobb first gastly is
just a bunch of dead people
ultra son says that gas emanating from a
graveyard was possessed by the
grievances of the deceased and thus
became a pokemon remember when I said
yah mask and kapha Garrigues have some
vicious cycle of murder and returning as
a ghost going on gastly Haunter and
Gengar have that in spades haunters
tongue will straight-up steal your life
away if it licks you but at least the
Pokedex warns you about not approaching
it
Gengar is a different story this purple
freak actively seeks out its victims
according to son should you feel
yourself attacked by a sudden chill it
is evidence of an approaching Gengar
there is no escaping it give up give up
even the Pokedex knows you're screwed if
Gengar is around pokemon has a few
murderers but Gengar is a full-on serial
killer
so enjoy pokemon sword and shield
everybody I'm sure whatever pair of
games we get next will have its fair
share of disturbing Pokemon - I've been
your host Tony and that's weird it just
got really cold in here anyway I'm Tony
and
you